what do you guys think men's part of
this in this entire equation like what
do men contribute to this to this [__]
what do you mentioned how is this how is
this situation how can men take
responsibility for this Behavior
for women being frustrated that they
have to keep up yeah a lot of the
aggravation a lot of you know like a lot
of complaints that they have because I
mean it's my view I mean if you take a
look around a lot of men they're not
strong masculine or virtuous they don't
form a strong tribe you know the way of
men is a way of the gang sort of thing
like you know strong men always form a
gang and they hold each other
accountable they do important things
they're competent they're skilled they
have combat skills they know how to make
money they can solve problems they're
masculine they don't put up with
[__] they don't deal with mind
manipulation there's a lot of weak men
out there too right so I think yeah you
know if you're gonna you know if you're
gonna point at women and blame women for
a lot of this then I think that there's
you know something to be said about the
state of men today too yeah
um
yes but also I kind of think that
the way that men can be
responsible
or take responsibility
for this type of reaction is by avoiding
women that complain
yeah but I mean the problem is is that
that doesn't really solve anything
because because there's enough people
that they're willing to give an audience
to
any victim mindset all the time whether
it's men or women I think anybody out
there that wants to play the victim card
there's always some part of the world
that is plenty it's it's plentiful like
it's everywhere right the government you
the media yeah somebody will will give
them a down to be like yeah you're right
you know you're a victim you know it's
so unfair blah blah blah let's go and
blame the patriarchy or something or
whatever it happens to be at that time
you've uh beaten this subject to death I
mean you know what the reply to that is
you know what the answer is
men being better men being more
masculine in a way that contributes the
world and contributes women as well
if it's more men were better leaders and
talked more about reality you know the
red pill stuff
things could go a lot better I think
that's maybe men's part everyone kind of
goes along with the blue pill stuff and
you know a lot of that Barbie monologue
was just wishing reality didn't
existence is you got those plugged in
guys that like you know subscribe to the
lies at media mainstream government
School uh Hollywood everything that's
that's sold to them then you got the
guys that are like okay like you know
we'll call them the red pill guys right
that see the stuff and then out of the
percentage of guys that see the stuff
and they understand it let me ask you
this question what what percentage of
those guys actually do something
different with their life and improve
their lives and actually level
themselves up
guys
barely even that yeah right yeah
but yeah I think if there were more good
leaders if more men were actually the
leader of their own household and led to
women in their lives the women in their
lives that feel a lot more comfortable
because someone's actually taken the
helm and they don't have to freak out
they don't like being in positions of
power typically and so they feel
uncomfortable they that's when things
kind of go shaky and some of their
uh less positive attributes take hold
and they do the underhanded stuff like
we were talking about the queen bee
thing in the chat there when women reach
the top they kind of get catty and play
some of those games and stuff like that
but if more men were actually leaders in
their own lives then
less of this imaginary
BS that isn't actually happening would
be taking hold if that makes sense
are you rich are you looking for like
the
um gordian knot type of solution what's
the gordia not explain that
it's like um
an old
um I think it's a Story a tale
and there was this not impossible to
undo
and the person that find like there was
a challenge where you had to untie this
knot and the person that had finally
solved the challenge just cut it in half
and the point is that some solutions are
like uh you have you find a solution to
a problem that solves everything in one
swift move
you know I could I mean I could solve
The World's problems in a few Swifts
move if people just follow proper
instructions but they never do
I mean like you can barely get guys to
do 25 push-ups
what's it called the gordian knot yeah
Alexander the Great it's a legend
uh Guardian not meeting Alexander the
Great yeah I'll look that up
um we used to have this in school of
course it's a Greek legend my friend
yeah
we used to have this in school where
um you had minimum uh physical
um where's the requirements yeah those
are fat kids had to go to special PE
Ace yeah yeah yeah no honestly they
don't do that anymore like uh this is
every school not just in Romanians every
school in at least until 10 years ago
had this we had Presidential Fitness
standards is what they call them in the
90s
well if have you guys ever seen those
videos from like the 40s and 50s of kids
doing PE class yeah swinging from the um
here let me grab one real quick there's
also videos online from like the 40s and
50s that explain how to be pretty did
you ever see those ones yep had to be a
pleasant wife how to greet your men when
you come from yeah basically you know
conventional feminine you know like I
ideals right because that was when men
would go to work and bring home the
bacon and she would cook it up sort of
thing but that that social contract has
changed obviously
um
Rich that's kind of what I'm wondering
about this Barbie movie too that it's if
you notice the book mind virus has gone
through and destroyed anything from our
childhoods any franchises they nailed
Star Wars ice like Power Rangers as a
kid they knocked that one out a few
years ago just completely after the
franchise and where I live people are a
little more conservative side here in
the city not so much but as a whole in
the country it's still very Catholic and
still a lot of those old school values
it's changing very quickly but I noticed
the same way in which a lot of Mexican
girls are Latin girls even adults in
like senoras they like Disneyland they
always wear the little Mickey Mouse ears
they went nuts over Barbie so I think
it's one of those things where okay it
scratched that that itch for Nostalgia
from their childhood they go to these
things there's a pink tax too so they
buy all the the jackets and uh and all
of the makeup and the little Barbie hair
streamers that everyone was wearing pink
here when that movie came out and then
they go there thinking that okay this is
going to be nostalgic and then they
insert these subtle left-leaning
messages in there to try to to try to
get their head I think there's I think
there's more layers to it in terms of
why it's so popular but at surface level
your average feminine chicks like oh
Barbie cool I used to play with Barbie
when I was a girl I'll go check it out
because they don't make good movies
anymore and then then they start getting
them
I just want to I just want to like put
this up I mean this is like a minute
long clip it's like a trailer of like a
high school somewhere in looks like
Britain this is British pathway I don't
know what that is but look at the Speed
and Agility with which these teenage
boys rip through this obstacle course
and the physical condition that they're
in right
like like flying through this thing they
like there's no fat kid slowing anything
down they're all in good physical
condition I mean they're push-up form
sucks not like it's it's horrible
I mean you know you would you know you
could argue that you've got you know
good strong young virtuous men there's
no
you know Geeks or weirdos in this uh
crowd there's no purple hair there's
like nothing it's it's you know
conventionally strong match like
you guys have probably heard what
China's doing they're they're banning
like anything that like makes men look
like sissies or Banning
um like anything that weakens the
physical mail
um anything like that it's just it's
just crazy that you know this is this is
1962. right like if you go to a high
school gym class today you won't see
anything close to that not even close
well like welcome to processed food and
McDonald's and like no anti-anxiety meds
and big Pharma and you know men are men
are toxic like 50 years ago nobody was
fat right like it was just you look at
like photos from a mall
from 50 years ago and everybody's just
um yeah like they're not overweight and
uh no purple hair like they're normal
though right like I don't yeah I don't
know I don't get it in certain places in
the world like I don't know like
you go to Nigeria or wherever you know
where people actually have to like work
where they have to like you know walk
and do stuff nobody's overweight there
right yeah
it's yeah check this out so this is the
other one that I referenced was the how
to be pretty uh clip so this is the
1940s guide for high school girls
um actually here I don't think I shared
the audio uh yeah they used to do
homemak
oh dude this is beyond helmack I mean
yeah they used to do whole Mech but yeah
um just let me know if you can hear this
when I play this
the way you look
now I've heard it said that we wouldn't
attached too much important tomorrow can
you guys hear that yeah yeah
okay first of all take a look at the
audience of women no zero tattoos zero
tattoos zero weird piercings zero like
bad haircuts with like purple green none
of that stuff right like just
conventional feminine gals right well
the way we look
important
and I'll talk about good appearance or
for grooming or look in your bed you
probably didn't really they are pose or
hairstyle or makeup
well I realize that those things are
especially interesting to you and they
are important and I am going to talk
about
uh
please remember that they are just
really the timing
just like the icing on the cake if the
icing is very good that's fine but if a
cake itself isn't good I don't know how
they did their hair like that it's like
every chick in the 1940s had the exact
same layered rolled sort of thing going
on
later
basically of course good health and
intelligent physical care are the
foundations of all Beauty
so the foundations of feminine beauty
good health and self-care right makes
sense
shining eyes lovely skin shining eyes
right a beautiful smile and loads of Pep
but we can't have them except in a
healthy clean body and I mean clean
remember you can't have good looks
without soap and water there's no
substitute for the daily bath as a
groundwork for glamor brilliant teeth
need brushing gleaming hair means
frequent and thorough shampooing and
keep that air refreshness by using a
deodorant regularly it's a shortcut to
Social Security
I mean this is like probably when they
use aluminum antiperspirant deodorant
type of products but
check out check out the gals you know
sitting here in bed together in the same
bedroom uh probably like writing in
their Diaries or something about some
guy listening you know with a record
player in the middle everyone knows real
women don't shave their armpits
mining sleep not just go to bed if that
means sitting up writing letters or
listening to music
I've seen lots of so back in these days
what kept girls up was writing the
letters and listening to music today it
screens right
and good connection sacrifice to swing
record at bedtime I'm all for music in
this place but there's a lot of sound
safe in that old expression beautifully
so it's not about that light early
enough every night you'll get eight or
nine hours of its most effective Beauty
treatment
and then there's this business of eating
it worries me to see that so many girls
think a balanced diet consists of soda
pop and a sandwich or a big buoy sundae
let's remember what we're taught in home
economics about a well-balanced diet
meat cheese eggs or fish milk butter
bread fresh fruits especially citrus
fruit green and starchy vegetables in
proper proportions and of course some
sweets
I mean it's pretty reasonable it's it's
probably not the best diet but then
again people moved more and ate better
back then anyways no high fructose corn
syrup yeah we didn't have like sugar
later crack crap and preservative
letting crap and
um seed oils and everything
so watch it girl it paid big dividends
outdoor
and when I say exercise many of you may
think of work well a little work is a
helpful Beauty hint but so is outdoor
play
I'll leave it to your own cup like
they're all attractive they're I mean
they're all like they're not tens but
they're all genuinely positively mostly
very attractive right whether you work
in the garden ride a bike play ball hike
they're playful they're sweet
every day can help to make you more
graceful but not if you do them not the
most graceful way to climb stairs but
still you know you know use the stairs
right
oh it can be good body conditioning you
could use your muscles to do them
vigorously instead of lunging I guess
that's the example
you had to rip it up there
I'd like to speak to you please
go right ahead I Wonder Girl throughout
these questions so I guess I have what
you call the round thing and I wear my
hair the way you said I shouldn't but I
don't see how things like that and
pasture and mannerisms and the other
things will make a girl more popular if
she's not pretty to begin with
sometimes I'd like to shake you girls
when you worry so much about being
pretty or not being pretty
shake you girls well slowly there's one
that's overlooked you've been just one
month doing everything I talked about to
make the most of your appearance you
wouldn't need to worry about being
pretty or popular
I wish that I could wear the magic wands
to show you what the difference would be
I mean you know I think this is a girl
that was objectively saying that she's
not naturally pretty but I mean if you
compare her to the average girl today I
think people in the comments would have
a much different opinion anyway I just I
decided to bring that up there as a bit
of a follow-up no she's made she's made
she's mad
but being being fit and pleasant in
general I believe that adds a lot of
Attraction points especially in the
modern day where there's not really a
lot of competition I say this to my guys
all the time like guys just get in shape
and kind of have an idea of who you are
and how you need to show up in the world
and you have no competition the same
thing goes for women a lot of women that
I know personally we talk about these
types things a lot of women are actually
more red pill than you give them credit
for in fact I'd say more more so than
guys because they know these games they
know how the dating Market works because
they're pursued by men so often and a
lot of them I make the point that uh
this left this woke mind virus it seems
to destroy feminine too and take away
the feminine power which a lot of women
don't even know what that means
yeah well said
solid point I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out